new restrictions on gatherings in
england are being revealed tonight by
downing street our deputy political
editor sam coats has the details
so what are the changes sam and how
significant is it that restrictions for
the whole of england are being brought
back in
tomorrow boris johnson will announce the
most significant reversal of restriction
of lockdown easing restrictions
to date he will say that from monday in
england
the number of people who can gather in
pubs and parks
and perhaps most significantly in homes
will be reduced from
30 down to six if you are in a group of
seven people you face a fine from the
police of 100 pounds
for your first offense rising to 3
200 pounds for the multiple offences
now downing street are arguing that this
is a consequence of the rise in
coronavirus cases
nearly 3 000 for the last three days
in a row but it will put pressure on the
government's wider coronavirus
response why a case is spiking when the
test and trace system
is meant to be damping it down all
account across the country and now has
been
in place for several months it comes on
a day that has seen
tests run out and the head of testing in
the nhs test and trace system having to
apologize
for that fact and it all comes as boris
johnson
experiences a hurricane at the start of
this new parliamentary term
taking on his own backbenchers as well
as the eu on brexit is not an entree
that he would wish on his enemies